then a brand-new interview Wendy can't
seem to hide just how much the split has
taken a toll on her I am going through a
situation in my family this is very
complicated
with every no is there a don't ask is
there a change now whoa girl Wendy broke
down in tears several times during the
hour-long interview with the 55 year old
confirmed she will never reconcile with
her ex the couple split in April after
21 years of marriage amid allegations of
emotional abuse and fathering a child
with another woman changed out there the
credit cards and the bank accounts and
everything to change it no my name is
Wendy hunter and that's my son's name
Williams opens up on Sirius XM's the
Karen hunter show airing tomorrow she
even gets candid about her recent stay
in a sober-living house there were
things in my life going on where I knew
I had to sit and quiet everything I came
out swinging
it's only because I'm a thinker I'm a
plotter or a planner and I have what
futuristic vision that futuristic vision
includes bringing her life story to TV
I'm executive producing my biopic Judy
begins this fall for the Lifetime movie
that we're told will include details of
the 55 year olds marriage and breakup
there's also a documentary in the works
so the movie will be two hours and then
the documentary is gonna be two hours
and their joint it's like a Wendy night
on lifetime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]